>> Mike: LATER TONIGHT, CATCH
ANTHONY ANDERSON GUEST COASTING
""JIMMY KIMMEL LIVE"" WITH
OFFSET AND ROBIN THICKE.
BACK HERE GAME SIX IN MILWAUKEE.
THIS WAS BEFORE THE GAME.
AN INTERESTING LONG DISCUSSION.
SCOTT FOSTER AND CHRIS PAUL.
FOSTER, ONE OF THE TOP-RATED AND
MOST RESPECTED OFFICIALS FOR
YEARS IN HIS 22nd FINALS GAME,
BUT HE IS NOT CHRIS PAUL'S
FAVORITE OFFICIAL.
PERHAPS HIS LEAST FAVORITE, AND
PAUL HAS TALKED ABOUT HIS TEAM'S
POOR RECORD -- AS AYTON
MISSES -- WHEN HE'S OFFICIATED
THE GAMES.
GOOD JOB FROM AYTON.
BOOKER CAN'T HIT THE THREE.
CHRIS PAUL DOESN'T THINK IT'S A
COINCIDENCE.
NICE TO SEE THE TWO OF THEM
TALKING BEFORE THE GAME.
ANTETOKOUNMPO, THE OFFENSIVE
REBOUND.
LOPEZ FOR THREE.